ciao ciao amico già troppo tardi però
no perché se siamo primi e farlo ogni
volta che vogliono fare un video sempre
in mezzo al bello attenti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono vari
genere ci siamo tornati sono apre con
pietro che ciao ciao pietro ciò che è
praticamente sempre bene agosto cretino
allora visto che ha avuto un successo
che lavora messa se ne sta avendo un
successo incredibile non so perché non
ho mai fatto ma mai kraft che il money e
arrivano che è un piacere qua ho trovato
delle uova acqua fuori il che non so
bene che ci sono delle uova
ciò delle uova e te lo giuro cioè delle
uova nei alimentare viene contrato delle
uova di gallina che o lei cagate tu
perché ho visto che ti sei accoppiato
con le galline può comunque sia e ci
servono per creare ali tripoli o
vecchiato il giorno aspetta ma poi è un
pollo se continui a colpirlo con le sue
stesse o poi si sicuro dai bastardo
saperlo basket lo sapevo che non avresti
fatto bene comunque in tutto questo
ragazzi dell'ultimo episodio abbiamo
fatto delle cose incredibili perché
siamo riusciti a finire bene qua 4
lancio matera 13 d'angelo e stavolta
facciamo quello che aveva promesso vero
la casa subacquea che questa può di
fronte a noi io prima di entrare in pose
ray le cose troppo di valore visto che
16 arkin poker inventario ai cibo tullio
se gli pezzi di pane che in teoria mi
bastano però ci prenderemo passate qui
no qui posso passate un po dobbiamo fare
sopra una sola deposito perché non
abbiamo più spazio per mettere niente ci
siamo direi che
l'ultima volta che abbiamo fatto questa
sinistra stavolta a questi utilizzo la
copertina in modo abbastanza click day
facciamo la casa sott'acqua che è questa
qui io non ho ancora capito il perché
c'è una luce che proviene da dentro c'è
immagine di quello che chiuso e sport
cibo perché vi va bene ma questo che
volevo fare era perché non si vede bene
sott'acqua maledizione volevo fare uno
screen bello per la copertina aprì la
porta pirla no si entra salve non sò se
è contento che siamo entrati
poverino lasciava ha fatto niente ma noi
ci aveva fatto niente magari voleva solo
accoglierci a posto da gioco finito
andare via ora d'acqua che scorre di
fuori c'è se questa geniale rito che
pensa te lo volevo farlo è un venditore
di forte smettila di produrre la futura
palo salve ma questo invece vende pale
salve miracle plate a questo vende carne
cioè lecce tutti sanno cosa senti a
parte trovare venditori di cose questo
io tornerei su non abitiamo ritornare su
4 st vacca in questo 5 sotto una perdita
in un mio so noi abbiamo formato
prepararsi psicologicamente ma non c'è
qualcosa con sotto è che lo sapete io
sono sherlock holmes ragazzi giuste
robert trevi diamante prendi tu prendo
io prendiamo neanche se mori colpa tua
madra quanto è grande il suo dungeon da
chiaramente questo ne siamo nella casa
delle streghe dove che cosa ti aspetta
ma lei uccisa
sì sì ma chi è che sbaglia è vero che è
il mana che sbatte le porte che a cena
c'è lo zombie che hanno scatenato la
logica 6 biocca lo saprei anche 1 per
noi
como torna anche male che male insomma
sì molto tu per un attimo voce diritto
cioè anni calmati
perché in ogni è diventato the walking
dead sto video scambiamoci nati qua c'è
un altro zombie che potevano a sfondarle
parte quanti zombie basta ho sentito
solo farlo ma è morto è morto qualche
effetto
ma quanta gente centro posto validazione
mente
oddio basta avete rotto le palle quante
persone è ovvio c'è la strega mette le
torce intanto non lo torce come questo
momento il pitone colpito ma iniziando
affatto un male cane vi sarà invece
hanno recuperato subito dietro e pieno
pieno è pieno di mosse ma siamo in pieno
è ancora la difficoltà non è vero è già
bella immagine 26 fine quando tira
dietro c'era nessuno ma guardati intorno
e siamo passati dietro non la guarda di
giro di questo l'habitat ivan edizione
in gioco in caserma ed europee
la somma di partita quando hai spaccato
di rispondere sì mi dai delle torce che
non ce l'avevi tienine sono oltre
intavolò occhio qua c'è uno a reggio
invisibile l'ora è fugato invisibile può
solo il 10 degli cure e l'invisibile
certo c'è un tenero per avere visibile
ma come non lo so mai vista 9 piacere ma
possono diventare visibili mostri e a
quanto pare poi lastri oded rende
invisibili
non lo sapevo sta roba perché mani
anch'io ma anch'io problemi in avanti
basta zombie maledizione
io vi ho trovato tutto è di fatto bene
fin da questa porta abbiamo avanti di
licola
va bene la loren aspetta sta votando si
stava registrando per marmi è perfetto
ovvio che c'è gente ovunque
passiamo prima di qua prendere quella
mettono dentro
cosa c'è di fido è una prigione questa
compagno di cella che cosa hai fatto per
essere qua dentro a ce ne sono due si
ingrossavano gli ho visti andiamo allora
sarai perché non inventano una macchina
di tortura solo ed esclusivamente per te
grazie
io ci credo in queste cose perché andai
adesso scendo di qua io faccio come
prison break
c'è un'altra porta quando però invece
sul web che poi c'è qua losco scala che
porta solo ci sono due amichetti che mi
sa che ci spareranno tra ecco mi ha
fatto male se ti interessa saperlo c'è
ancora vivo eva ammazzalo ma erano
davvero una più di amber qua se vuoi
diventa quanto quanto 20 20 secondi
migliora muoio muoio non puoi morire un
quello hanno posto arrivano non poi li
lascio anche un cuore quale vediamo
questo popolo del no va bene con quattro
cuori ma vado io
even perfetto la partenza è buona
odierno c'è un altro fi per occhio scusa
sublime ok buono torce c'è una leva qua
era per accendere la luce abbiamo fatto
abbia finito e abbia finito poi mio zio
alla casa sotterranee la mia completata
ragazza è tenuta la difficoltà massimo
vera 11 libero allora siamo anche
migliorati rispetto del più forte ora si
chiamava giocavamo di brutto però direi
di uscire mica fessi gialli ma poi fai a
correre
no no no non usciremo uscire non uscire
non uscire ma stanno guardando breaking
bad a aia scherzavo quindi è un cretino
fai qualcosa una volta ho visto in the
jump one se ti giuro mi ha fatto lo
stesso effetto che schifo fa veramente
schifo te lo giuro anche si muovano il
bong ma come e guarda per un secondo
come vede le bong è appena sentito
fumare pietro subito bravo vendevo come
se non intendevo questo è stata nel
camino cosa vi serve che sono stato
perfetto cartello next e va a dormire
prima che notte e ogni volta così come
fate a far tutto storto a ne ha fatta
un'altra
ho visto solo da dormire
penso che buongiorno allora abbiamo
fatto quello tutto a sinistra l'abbiamo
fatto perché sono qua era il regalo un
giorno mi di tempio romano abbiamo fatto
anche questo sono 2000 abbiamo fatto no
no questo the water tempo non l'abbiamo
fatto e guarda e del tempo mancano
questi due
ok facciamo fare il tempo il primo amico
amico a quel tempo difficoltà easy dove
è facile ma non riesco a vederlo qui di
traffico facile cosa numero
eccole coloro che dovendo e davanti a me
ti metto dentro fa poi entra
grazie entra insieme a me
ora che abbiamo la casa tutto si vabbè
ma ecco rimesso i ricordi quel posto in
visto il tipo il primo episodio non è
vero non ci credi guarda allora abbiamo
già respirato abbiamo già ficcata quando
scopre di aver fatto un compito che ti
aveva segnato dalla profumeria
che figata incredibile quindi abbiamo
già fatto un d'angelo senza saperlo bene
ma sai che avevano dimenticato ma
anch'io per fantastico fantastico bene e
allora del tempo la posto ecco ci siamo
subito il cartello già fatto pure fatto
tuna ci sono io
sì sono convinto che siamo fortunati per
questo motivo mancano water tempo
e a questo punto dragons liquidi water
tempo necstour anni subito così poi per
farmi mangiare che ho fame queste
spedizioni da boy scout richiedono un
sacco di forze amiche mi prendi questo
non vedo cosa cosa la pena parava poi
stavo annegando
prendo è una torta di una cosa che aiuta
aiutami aiutami pietro che trovai anche
magliaia cos'è la donna che dolore ferma
a 0 a brescia è fermo una sega per
dietro come sempre tutte le cose che
gates buona buona non bene e non mi sono
pagato ma legion parte che era già
aperto qua allora è stato il gripen una
cesta con i droni gli amanti nero di
seppia e il medico respiri c'e un 3 mio
puoi respirare
respirate no però tipo molto di più
l'aria ma da quanto è grosso e lo so no
a breve ma un casino e pieno di acqua ci
serve la spugna e una volta sia orca
vacca ci sono quei cosi che c'erano
anche la più episodio nella calde sì sì
il primo peso aveva fatto una parte di
questo dungeon ti ricordi ma nel
segmento vedono messi quanti spin off in
questo video quello sia morti ma maglia
che ricordo ante cose stiamo scoprendo
oggi si già passato di qua sicuramente
no ecco se prima e questo è il punto
delle entrate che mi piazzo incredibile
è vero ma dai e non abbiamo papa quando
si morbi però non aver visto tutta sta
roba
abbiamo riferendo non aveva visto che il
lancio proseguiva di qua ma se scegli
completamente ma quanta roba per
l'aspetto arrivare commercio tra falsi
dell'opera di ce la faccio adesso povero
uno spear inter ne ho già due uno
spoiler dato bene dietro ma quindi noi
abbiamo anche notato la zona dove c'è la
migliore scelta dove abbiamo trovato
subito la spada fortissima è vero che
con l'altro contiene sono qua lo
rispetto è stata aspetto ci sono un
botto qua
l'havana malissimo 26 indietro special
operando un botto meccoli madonna nera
menaye manager spacca ai quarti sono
kakà che vale tanto malissimo sono
malissimo adesso si fanno molto male
basta quanto li metto sul sushi sui
colleghi rimane che si o no ma
sottolineo ancora guardato qui sotto no
perché c'è anche lo sposo figure vado
mai rompe lo sposerà ti copro no no no
civili
ahia ahia malizia quando veramente male
psicologia pensa che siamo super
equipaggi se non fossimo in qualche anno
i morti venti volte infatti ma tipo 30
40 volte anche perché sistema scherzando
tutte le cose che ho addosso dobbiamo
tenere ben presente ago dell'ente
comunque siamo stati bravi anche
stavolta cioè alla fine ce la siamo
cavata bene allora mi sono ritirato di
mettere il cartello però va bè metti lo
faccio io
se abbiamo la prima la seconda la terza
che abbiamo fatto già senza volerlo
questa che un pezzo l'avevamo già
scoperto però abbiamo fitto di
controllarla quella della settimana
scorsa di come ho fatto a sopravvivere
che lo so solo io
la casa subacquea delle streghe manca
del traino slayer che è l'ultima hai
messo che vedrà cosa hai scritto stato
avresti insulto dei tuoi scemo killer a
parma jean marais che sembra senza
neanche andarci perché lo sapevo già
quindi ragazzi su tutte le cose che
abbiamo fatto l'unica cosa che rimane
ormai è del treno slam
quindi la caverna del drago player è
cosa vuol dire che aveva battello ci
sfuggì uccisore maggio si è
completamente scegliere lei e che
livello non sei cavalli in video
l'inglese di matteo renzi aspettava
tanta ma vuol dire tanto
quindi ragazzi io spero che questo video
vi sia piaciuto giocare con pietro
il piacere anche perché facciamo un
sacco di cose insieme io no non andare
in onda veicoli nuovi di salute veloce
ma perché come click detto nel prossimo
video è l'ultima è l'ultima che averne
la più difficile di tutti abbiamo fatto
tutte 6 manca la settima stai buono per
cortesia che vi chiedo perché ancora
nobel per l'intelligenza mente lo
abbiano dato me lo sto chiedendo te lo
giuro ogni tanto c'è questo dubbio io
voglio fare nella realtà questa cosa
fonte vicina posso ragazzi spero che
questo video vi sia piaciuto abbiamo
completato tutti i lager
non so parlare abbiamo completato di
tutti i dungeon che abbiamo trovato
intorno all'isola tranne dragons den se
pietro magari la smetta di fare queste
cose mentre faccio la oltre meglio
grazie bene poi ti fanno il primo
episodio questo save e nelle prigioni
crociato momento mi piace anche ai
cerchi da te descrizione senza
l'assistente che ci vediamo al prossimo
tutto dove batteremo il drago ci ha
messo infatti giusta di nono mancato ma
si aspetta 9 mila ragazzi
[Musica]